And now the old scout master.
This news just in from the large Baden Collider in Zern, Switzerland, where scout physicists
have discovered that the number of 10 steaks is always T minus 1, where T is the number
of steaks required.
We now return you to your regularly scheduled podcast.
How about that?
You learn something new every day, don't you?
Hey, this is podcast number 181..
Well, welcome back to the Scout Master Podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Hey, if you're a little confused, you know, join the club.
Podcast 180 was scheduled to go out while I was away at summer camp and
something got a little kazooing than the Genekte Kazooink
And it didn't go out until a little bit later.
So we've had a podcast. 180 has applied to the past two weeks,
And that's just the way that things work around here sometimes.
I'm getting ready this week to leave for our annual canoe trip up to Algonquin
Provincial Park in Ontario, Canada,
And it's very busy.
We're taking 25 up to Algonquin this summer.
So we may have a podcast on August 12th, next Monday,
And you know what?
We may not,
But we'll definitely be back on Monday, August 19th
And keep our regularly scheduled podcast every week on Monday, moving right along.
So I appreciate your patience and understanding with that.
Oh my,
We had a wonderful week at summer camp.
We had an extraordinarily good senior patrol leader who,
who assumed that it was his responsibility to do everything.
Can I tell you a little story here?
Give me just a moment, because this is kind of cool.
My senior patrol leader this year- he's 15 years old.
My senior patrol leader at camp this year- he's 15 years old
And I first met when he was about three or four years old in a stroller at camp.
His mom and dad, who were great scouting friends of mine
and fellow staff members years and years ago at this same scout camp,
had brought him down for a visit, you know, a decade or so ago.
And of course it's great to keep up with the people you know from camp
And we've kept up with the years. and his dad became a cub master
and he went through cubs and everything like that
And when it became time for them to move on into a scout troop,
they came and joined our scout troop.
He's been with us these past four years.
He got the role of senior patrol leader
And it just struck me as I was sitting there in camp,
as I was watching him lead the troop through the retreat ceremony
and all the other things, just what an amazing thing scouting is
and all the connections that we form.
So you know there were a couple of moments there at camp
where the old man choked up a little bit
But, wow, what a great thing to be involved in.
And I heard from a lot of you while I was away.
I've got two or three that we picked out for the mailbag.
Barry Carney is an adult volunteer with a scout troop two in Downingtown, PA,
And he said: I have two questions really,
What do you think makes a successful scout troop?
The key elements.
And I've been asked to take over as scout master.
I said it's seriously considerate,
but I'm just trying to figure out how and where to start.
Barry, you're right here in our neighborhood.
It'd be great to meet with you,
but I've got a very simple answer.
If you're looking for the key element
that makes a successful boy scout troop, there's only one
and that's the patrol system
And out of that everything flows.
All of the youth leadership, all of the advancement,
all of the things that we want to see happen
in the lives of our scouts comes out of the patrol system.
That's the simple answer.
You know I could talk for hours and hours-
and I have- about the patrol system
and the way that it works and why it's so important,
But that's where I would start
And, yeah, take over as scout master,
You'll have a grand time with it.
I certainly have.
Thanks for getting in touch, Barry.
Paul Coutts is an adult volunteer with troop 9-11
in Eden Prairie, Minnesota,
And Paul also has a really great website and blog
at boyscouttrail- all one word boyscouttrailcom.
He wrote in to say that he put my post
changing Eagle required merit badges on his site.
He said my blog's been pretty quiet the past few months,
with starting up this new troop
taking much more time than it should.
We're troop 9-11 with a slight emphasis
on be prepared for emergencies.
The five guys go on their first camping troop next week
and, Paul, that's great news.
I'll be posting more on my Ice Age trail hike.
for seven weeks starting around August 1st.
I'm promoting the Scout Strong program
and I hope to meet a bunch of troops
across Wisconsin as I walk.
Thanks for all your efforts to promote,
explain and improve scouting.
Scout on,
And that's from Paul.
Paul, do the same.
We'll definitely be following that Ice Age trail hike
And good luck with the new troop too.
That sounds exciting.
Kevin Smith is with troop 696 in Mesa, Arizona,
And he wrote in to say this:
Clark, you're heaven sent for Scouters.
Thanks, Kevin.
I would note that you know
so are meteorites and things like that.
But here's a website I found
I'm making old style neckerchiefs
And I thought you could pass it on.
Thanks for all you do,
Kevin. I'm definitely going to do that.
I've got it queued up and ready to go for next week.
Well, I'm away in Canada,
So keep an eye on the blog, folks,
And you'll see exactly what Kevin is talking about.
And finally, we heard from Gary Klotz
is a Scoutmaster in troop 383
in Orland Park, Illinois.
I'm not going to read the entirety of the message.
Basically, it's kind of a litany of the frustrations
that we all have, no doubt
in trying to stay connected with our district
and our council and trying to utilize
some of the resources there.
You're not alone.
Things happen
And sometimes we kind of get left out in the cold.
We're waiting for the cavalry to come
and nobody shows up.
At the conclusion of his message,
Jerry says this:
I'm writing because I really don't know where to turn.
Our council seems kind of useless as far as I'm concerned,
It's never provided us any support or help.
Is there some place I can turn for help
to get the training we need for our leaders?
Is there another way I can request a new commissioner
that will help us and at least remain in contact with us?
If it wasn't for the boys being so gung-ho
and wanting to remain in scouts and wanting to advance,
I think I would have given up some time ago.
Well, Jerry, everybody feels like that from time to time.
Even after 30 years,
I feel these frustrations sometimes.
I think a lot of it has to do with just the nature
of who we are as an organization
And unfortunately,
unfortunately there's
unfortunately we're not as attentive as we need to be
and not as supportive as we need to be all the time.
So here's what I would do:
I did a little research,
I found out where your district is
and a couple of names,
and I've sent them to you.
Get in touch with them
and tell them the exact same thing
that you told me
And you know,
reiterate that. cry for help
and insist on getting the support that you need
Sometimes. sometimes that'll work.
I'd be very interested to hear
what kind of reaction you get, Jerry.
So do be in touch.
If you have a message or a question,
you can get in touch too,
And the email address is Clark
C-L-A-R-K-E at scoutmastercgcom.
I'd love to hear what you've been up to this summer,
how things are going,
what you got planned for the fall,
And I've got a couple of things for you
in this podcast
that hopefully will be helpful
at this time of year.
First of all, we're going to talk a little bit
about uniforms and neckerchiefs
in Scout Master's ship
in seven minutes or less,
And then I've got an email question
to answer about
the annual plan
that your patrol leader's council
puts together.
So that's going to take up the rest of the podcast.
I think we ought to get started,
Don't you?
Let's get started,
Shall we?
Let's do the Master's ship in seven minutes
or less.
Did you know that August 1st
of every year is World Scarf Day?
That's right.
Scout neckerchiefs
and scarves or neckers
or whatever you call them
in your part of the world-
The only really unique
element of the Scout uniform.
I really don't know
of any other uniform group
that wears neckerchiefs like that
other than Scout-
Just as a standard piece of the uniform.
it's something that sets Scouts apart.
I'll tell you this story
As our group prepared
for our trip to Switzerland
in 2011,,
the Scouts were kind of
casting about
and they asked if they needed
to bring their uniforms.
Are we actually going to need them?
And I said, of course.
And they asked:
when are we going to have to wear them?
And I told them: all the time.
Now this went over
like a lead balloon.
Of course, they huddled together
and at one meeting
in preparation for this trip,
I was told by the youth leader
for the trip that they had voted
and they did not want to wear
their uniforms all the time,
if at all.
And if you're a regular reader
of the blog or a listener
to the podcast,
you know I'm really invested
in youth leadership
and I don't want to say no
And I don't want to veto
their decisions.
but this time I think
I had a pretty good reason to.
I explained a few things to them,
trying to get them
to understand the practical purpose
in my insistence
that we would wear a scout uniform
and that it would be worn
for the entirety of the trip.
For the first thing,
in airports and train stations
and other public places,
the scout uniform is pretty much
an instant recognition
that makes security checks
a little bit easier
or people more receptive
and helpful.
That's just the way it works
in my experience.
And number two was:
is that when you're in an unfamiliar place
with a bunch of your buddies
with, you may be tempted to do things
that you would give a second thought to
if you're in a scout uniform.
That's kind of a minor reason
on my part,
but I think it's important.
And number three was
when we have to move as a group
from trains to planes,
to boats, to buses
on tight schedules,
it's just going to be a lot easier
if we're in uniform.
And actually the hat that we wore
for our Switzerland trip,
which was the Centennial Baseball Cap,
proved to be the most useful part
of the uniform for this.
It was easy to spot it
in a crowd
and to keep everybody together.
I told the guys
going on the trip
that this was pretty much
absolutely non-negotiable
And while I knew it was likely
that I would be able to back down
from the idea of wearing uniforms
all the time,
it would be much more difficult
to start with saying that
we'd wear uniforms
on certain occasions
and not on others.
The scouts happily took
this pretty much in stride.
You know they weren't pleased,
but they know it's rare
that I insist on something like this
over what they would rather do.
I asked them why they didn't want
to wear the uniform.
The answer I got was:
you know, it's uncomfortable.
I think it's kind of physically
and psychically uncomfortable
for scout age boys sometimes
to put on that uniform.
They didn't come right out
and say that they were embarrassed
to wear it.
I know, and you know
and any scout leader knows,
many boys who are in those years
of 14,, 15, 16
aren't exactly thrilled
about wearing their uniform
in every place,
in every situation.
Now, as the trip progressed
I was able to kind of modify
the uniforms all the time role
to scout necrochips all the time
and trip t-shirts
most of the time.
Thus they could live with
and even enjoyed it.
We had a patch in a necrochip
that we created
and they were very popular
for trading with other scouts
at the scout center there
in Condorsteg.
Now those of you who've attended
some kind of international
scouting event
realize that just about
everyone wears a necrochip,
with or without their uniform.
As a matter of fact,
at Condorsteg International
Scout Center
the staff, the scouts,
the rovers, everyone
wore their necrochips
seemingly all of the time.
Some wore two or three different
necrochips at the same time.
There were lots of different
woggles or necrochip slides
and some folks
wore several of those,
and a lot of people
put pins on their necrochips
when they were wearing them as well,
and they didn't necessarily wear
the necrochip all tight
up around the collar,
They were kind of worn with the
ends knotted
and if they had a slide at all,
they were usually not
drawn all the way up.
Now scouts visit and shop
in the village,
the nearby village of
Condorsteg,
while they are staying at the center,
and they're able to ride the bus
back and forth from the village
for free if they're
wearing a necrochip.
In the rare event
residents of the village
encountered scouts
from the Scout Center
acting improperly.
You know what they would do:
They would call the Scout Center
and tell the staff there
what color necrochip
the scouts who were
misbehaving were wearing
and they would be able to figure out
and they would be able to deal with
whatever that misbehavior was.
Now, before I go any further,
here's what I'm not saying.
I'm not saying I dislike
scout uniforms.
I'm not advocating
some big policy change
or attempting to undermine
the long-standing tradition
of the scout uniform.
I think it's a very useful thing
and on all suitable occasions
it makes sense.
But I do think
a necrochip
makes a great activity uniform
and a reasonable, workable compromise
that scouts can take to pretty readily.
I've had the experience of them
doing just that.
I like the idea of troop t-shirts,
but they've always seemed to be a problem.
Scouts outgrow them,
they lose them.
they don't typically outgrow necrochips,
although they may lose them
from time to time.
But you know
necrochips don't come in sizes
for the most part,
So getting one
and getting it to a scout
is a pretty simple matter.
I'd like to change the uniform
and insignia guide where it says
that the necrochip is worn
only with the official uniform
and never with t-shirts
or civilian clothing,
to allow for just that.
I know a lot of troops
have the tradition of traveling
to and from outings and uniform
only to change them
when they arrive
to something more suitable
for the activity.
Our troop doesn't end up doing this
because it's impractical
for the most part
and to tell you the truth,
on 8 out of 10 trips
we'd be wearing jackets
or coats covering up
the uniform anyway.
It's just an idea.
I think it would be pretty widely accepted
and you know
we kind of have adopted
as a practice ourselves.
What I'd like to see
is I'd like to see it be
within official policy,
uniform policy. to make that happen,
You'll be able to tell me
your thoughts of this
on the blog,
or you can email me,
and you'll find out
how to do that
towards the end of the podcast.
Write me a letter,
Send it by name
Email- that is folks.
And here's an answer
to one of your emails.
Well, here's an email I received.
I'm not going to tell you where, from
or who
because I don't want
to cause some trouble.
I'm the committee chair
for our troop.
Our scout master filled me in
on the results
of the annual
program planning conference
and I wonder how you'd handle it.
The patrol leaders council
basically turned in a plan.
that hasn't changed much
from the last couple of years.
Looking back through troop history,
our themes and campouts
have seemed to have been
much more varied
and scouting oriented
at the time. I became associated
with the troop
10 plus years ago,
But then the adults
kind of took over
and that's when
the reputation started.
I'm afraid it's
squelching participation
because the been there,
done that effect
kicks in.
I don't look too closely
at what other troops do.
Is this typical
and is it okay.
There are a few things
that come to mind
when we're talking about
the annual program plan
that the patrol leaders council
puts together.
Now, of course, we're invested
in youth leadership,
but they need some guidance
on this,
And I really don't have
any problem with
scouts being repetitive
in their plans at all.
Scouts like to do things
that they know.
They don't have to invent them
out of whole cloth
every year.
I would say that
my guys repeat about 70%
of their calendar
from year to year
because that's what
they really like to do,
And within the course
of two or three years
they repeat about
100% of it.
I don't know where we
really get the idea
that we have to change
things up.
I think scouts
are happiest with
familiar surroundings
and activities
most of the time.
The patrol method
really doesn't imply
that everything needs
to be different
all the time.
not at all.
I think it's a mistake actually
to hand the patrol leaders
council a blank calendar
and tell them to make
everything up.
I think they find this
kind of tiresome
and I don't think
they get all that much
out of the process.
I think that
they'll come up
basically with a calendar
of activities that
repeats each year
and, if they have the option
to change things,
that's fine.
Telling them that
they have to reinvent
the wheel every year?
I don't know.
It's not something that
I'm going to do.
Been there, done that factor.
it's not a program problem,
it's a lack of imagination
and utilization
of the patrol system
on the part of
the leadership.
Scouts may be doing
the same activity
from year to year,
but if you're applying
the patrol system,
using your imagination
a little bit,
their roles
in that activity
change
each year.
The first year
they go,
it's all new,
they're learning
the ropes,
they're feeling challenged.
the second year,
they're getting more
familiar with the challenge
and they're
able to meet it better.
they may even have
a leadership role
by that time.
and the third year
they go,
they're making arrangements
and leading the activities.
the fourth year,
they're leading
the other youth leaders.
now the fifth, through
the seventh years
are the only times
that I would
worry about,
about the been there,
done that deal.
and when that happens,
you get creative.
hey,
John, you're going
backpacking right?
I'm really worried
about this one patrol.
get on them,
make sure they're getting
prepared.
they could really
use some help
on the trail too.
what
you aren't going,
oh my.
it would be
a big favor to me
if you did,
I could really
use your help.
of course,
John would
may respond yes,
he may respond no,
but if he has
actual responsibility,
if he's really
working to help somebody,
he's going to
feel pretty good
about that trip.
as for the content
of the calendar,
as for what
they decide
is a simple test
test. number one
is a patrol base.
to me,
there must be
some major element
of the activity
that leverages the patrol
system.
are the patrols
doing for themselves
or is it just
a big group activity?
are they cooking
for themselves?
are they setting up
their own patrol campsite?
I think that's
incredibly important.
now, you won't
be able to do that
on every
single outing,
but
I think
that needs to be.
a major element
of your outdoor
program
is: are there
advancement opportunities
in the first class?
this is.
I have a little bit
of tortured logic here.
follow me for a moment.
I don't want something
designed around
doing
requirements,
quote unquote.
I want activities
that, by the reason
of doing them,
result
in advancement
opportunities.
does that make sense
if we're
putting up tents
and cooking food
and exploring the
natural world
and tying knots,
not as some specific
requirement
based component,
but because
they're
integral to the activity.
do you get what I'm saying?
backpacking
is another great
is a great example of that.
you know
how many up to first
class requirements
can you fulfill
on a backpacking
trip?
take a look,
there's a lot of them.
and my third test is this:
is this something
that you
scouts
are making happen
for yourselves,
or is it just an activity
in which you become
participants?
now, those three questions
weed out
things like
amusement parks
and stuff like that,
because they don't check
any of those boxes.
if the scouts come up
with some idea
that doesn't really
work on those,
then they try to adjust it
and they say,
hey, well, you know,
we'll get in line
at the amusement park
by patrols
and patrols will have to
stick together.
isn't that enough?
well, no, not really.
I mean we're playing
the game of scouting
and that's camping
and that means
things like
setting up tents
and cooking for yourself
and working with your
patrol.
if the activity doesn't
check those boxes,
it's not something
that we're going to do.
I know a lot of troops
work on merit badges
as a part of their program.
I think it's a bad idea.
merit badges are
happen best
when there's
one or two scouts
and a counselor
working together on it-
part of the merit badge
process
is
that actual
going on
and finding that counselor
and talking to them.
that's a huge part
of the process
and we shortcut that
if we just do
merit badges
as a big giant group
of scouts
that patrol
doing a merit badge.
I don't really
have a problem with that.
it's a smaller group.
the patrol leader
has to make the arrangements.
that works for me.
if they're able to make
that happen,
I support that.
as a troop.
now
I don't think it's a good thing
to do merit badges
at troop meetings
or on weekend campouts.
so let's say
the patrol leaders
council
decides that they
want to go do this,
one of these ticketed
things.
they want to
go on
a luge run
or a ski trip
or a white water rafting trip
or something like that,
basically where you buy a ticket
and you stand in line
and you do the activity.
I'm going to tell them
that they need to
rethink that.
if they want to do some sledding,
how about a sledding weekend
where patrols
design and build the sleds
and they have a race
and we go camping
at a place
where there's a great hill?
if you use your imagination
and you start working
with them on that basis,
you can use
kind of your Jedi powers
and you never have to say
no,
you just guide them
towards something
that meets the three tests
that we talked about.
you noted that
the troop program seems to have changed
since you joined about a decade ago,
and I'll say that troop programs
can atrophy over time.
but it's not the content
of the program
that's at fault necessarily.
it may be the imagination
of the leadership
and the application
of the patrol system.
sometimes it's also a fear
that if we don't keep
changing things up,
if there's not something
new and interesting to do,
that scouts will grow
disinterested.
if they do the same activities
every year,
if they have real responsibility
for it
and their role changes
from year to year,
they don't get bored.
if everything gets done
for them,
if they buy a ticket
and they stand in line,
if they're just a participant
and they're not making it happen
for themselves,
they'll ride along.
they'll think it's fun
for a while
until they find something
more amusing to do
than scouts.
we hit on a lot
of different ideas there.
I hope it helps
to answer your questions
somewhat.
if you have a question
for me,
I'm going to find out
how to do that in just a moment.
Well, thanks for listening
to this edition
of Scoutmaster Podcast.
here's how to keep in touch.
read the Scoutmaster blog
at ScoutmasterCGcom
and, while you're there,
you can subscribe
to receive updates
to the blog by email.
you can also subscribe
to the Scoutmaster podcast
on iTunes
and, when you do,
feel free to leave a comment
or review or a rating,
you can access the podcast
on your mobile device
through Stitcher Smart Radio.
get details about
how to make that happen
at Stitchercom
and remember
we're out there
on the vast panorama
of social media outlets.
you can follow us
at Scoutmaster blog
on Facebook,
Tweet ScoutmasterCG
on Twitter,
and you can watch us
at ScoutmasterCG on YouTube.
and, by the way,
I've got a lot of stuff
we'll be rolling out
in the fall
on the YouTube channel,
so keep an eye on that.
you can join
the exclusive
ScoutmasterCG circle
on Google Plus.
if all of the
social media stuff
just leaves you flat,
I'll tell you what.
Bunky.
just email me,
zoom into the late 90s
and you can
email me
at
ScoutmasterCGcom.
the Scoutmaster blog
and the Scoutmaster podcast
are not official publications
of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed
or sponsored by
the Boy Scouts of America.
no, no, no,
it's just me.
I've got a microphone
and a laptop
and a little spare time
and I'm trying to
lend a hand to
scout leaders
and maybe have
a little bit
of fun along the way.
and speaking of fun,
it's just me,
I've got a microphone
and a laptop
and a little spare time
and I'm trying to
lend a hand to
scout leaders.
and speaking of fun,
before we go,
let's hear from
our founder,
Sir Robert Bidden Powell.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you
and Group Champion,
Why? thank you, sir,
until next time.
Until next time.